[Music]
thank you
welcome back to our next episode of
what's up Prof
hi Walter hi Martin you look quite cozy
yes I am
thermoregulating
yeah our weather has changed a little
bit here I don't know they call it
climate change
four times a year yes I call it winter
ah
we continue with our interesting
discussion on absentee landlord but
let's open with the word of prayer first
heavenly father it's a privilege to work
for you and yes odd we know that the
onslaughts will be many and we know that
we can rely upon you to help us through
everything so we ask now also again that
you bless our minds Enlighten our
Thoughts with the Holy Spirit and guide
this discussion in Jesus name amen amen
we've had an interesting weekend right
Martin yes it's hectic I mean between
all of the recordings and all the
WhatsApp profs we still work in some
Outreach to
different places we had a weekend full
of it basically uh District camp meeting
yeah
I went about 170 people right well
actually about 250. 250. yeah okay quite
nice
well but for a moment there I thought I
wasn't going to make it that was very
sick
but the Lord did a miracle he did a few
Miracles actually did a few Miracles and
I had a couple of guys in my corner
you know after each boxing round they
came and they gave me smelling salts
give me a couple of slaps on the left
and the right shoved something into my
veins yeah and then we went so
so um I think a lot of people heard
about this they were worried we got
thousands of emails I don't know why the
Grapevine is so strong it goes like a
wildfire yeah and um but just we will
show a picture or two a photo or two
we were on stage Walter you were there
we thank the Lord for the blessings and
the Miracles yes and we'll carry on well
carry on we will not lie down just
because he thinks he can
prevent us from doing what what we have
to do right but isn't it interesting our
what's a Prof the previous one where we
were discussing this of Job And yet when
he if he's slaves so it's your fault
it's all your fault
I was sitting and when I watched again
on Thursday I was thinking we were
actually looking for this we were
looking for trouble
well I got quite a whack but uh you know
it was just an infection and it wouldn't
go away and
had a lot of
high temperatures and but in between God
raised me up there we went
and we could do it and still now use
I'm wrapped in a blanket we're getting
you there we're getting you unwrapped in
a blanket fitting up before it again yes
at least the infection is over thank God
for that yeah so yeah we'll get through
all of this because what's in the on the
horizon is definitely not going to be a
walk in the park yes
it's it's hard you know you have all
these people coming and they're all
excited and then
the devil tries to prevent it but God is
mightier he just intervenes and there we
go and the way in which he helped and
the way in which it turned out was just
marvelous and it was a rallying point
people came together they prayed it was
nice you see God also uses situations
like this yes to get the people of God
connected again yeah perhaps we can have
got a few slides that we can see we'll
show a few of the photos of the camp
meeting and where we were actually
sitting on the stage yes it was a
totally different scenario and we didn't
know what how to it was improvising the
old time yeah so we had to sit
just to save some energy there but it
went one it went well we were talking
about the absentee landlord and it is an
inexhaustible subject really
because as we saw people that looked at
it at the first part they
started to get a glimpse as to why
people say there's an absentee landlord
but it's also important to remember why
Jesus said it is expedient that I go
away it's good for you it's good for you
so that the Holy Spirit can come and
that you can work by faith because faith
is the substance of things not seen not
seen so you have to you have to work by
faith and it is by faith that Abraham
was saved
and not as they do in the joint
statement on justification yes Twisted
all around so that it's a question of
works and grace alone yes we are under
grace that is true but it is by faith
that's it because without faith it is
impossible to please him and it is my
ease saving blood yes body saving Works
correct all these nuances that are so
subtle and so devious only a Jesuit
could pen something so devious
but
people must be getting the idea I don't
like what they stand for right yeah but
well I can I can confirm it I don't
and I stand with you on that thank you
Martin thank you I think uh the greatest
enemy of God's people that was raised up
to counter the Reformation just happens
to be the Jesuits whether people like it
or not
there are some amongst our ranks that
think the Jesuits are our friend
how can the Agents of the devil be
friends of God's people it's impossible
possible this is because when you try to
make peace between Satan and God that's
what you that's what you end up with
all right absentee landlord part two
all the lessons that we have to learn
during the absence of the landlord right
yeah
but as we saw is never absent because he
is present through his representative
the Holy Spirit exactly and through the
word like we saw and yes through prayer
Leviticus 19 verse 17 Thou shalt not
hate thy brother in thine heart Thou
shalt in any wise rebuke thy neighbor
and not suffer sin upon him
they
almost look contradictory to some people
right
yeah because if you are supposed to just
love then love in many cases is to
excuse everything
but in this case it says no Thou shalt
in any wise rebuke Thy Neighbor
and not suffer sin upon him so you have
to call Sin by its right name
but love covers a multitude of sins it's
the way in which you do it yeah that is
important when you rebuke the sin but it
is unfortunate that even though you
rebuke the sin The Sinner does not want
to hear it so he takes it that it's an
attack on him personally personal attack
that's why so many people reject the
spirit of Prophecy yes I was reading I
love reading what these Pioneers wrote
about the spirit of Prophecy and I have
this
huge book it's about the size it's like
keeping a table in front of you I like
those old books
and I saw all these photocopied things
about what they said and I was reading
what Elder Wilcox
had to say about the spirit of Prophecy
and he made some very interesting points
you know
he says people question is this now from
God is this her opinion is this that is
that the other and is it for her time
only it's surely not applicable to us
and all of these excuses
and he uses the example of Samuel
and Samuel was called as a young boy he
was still a child when he was called us
into the prophetic office
and and then the verse eventually says
and all Israel even from Dan all the way
through all of Israel
knew that Samuel had been established as
a prophet of the Lord they knew they
knew
so once somebody has been called into
the prophetic office and has been
established in the prophetic office do
you then go and question every time he
has something to say and say is this not
prophetic or is this not prophetic why
do you do that with the spirit of
Prophecy
it should be the same she was
established
and if she was established like Hulda
was established then what comes out of
the mouth is something that you better
take cognizance of that's it hey stop
kicking against stop kicking against the
Pricks amen and all of these nuances and
changes in theology that people have are
so vexing
I spoke to a young man at the camp
meeting
and he was so perplexed
because the
theologians at our institutes insist
that the new translations are correct
and that Jesus went into the most holy
and not into the holy when he ascended
into heaven yes now that's ancient yeah
that's of course Ford theology right and
they get it from unfortunately like you
said the new translations the new
translations even the new King James
translation and that's why they condemn
the King James but the con the King
James is correctly translated from the
original the others are incorrect
whether they like it or not and secondly
the King James is in harmony with the
spirit of Prophecy as well which
collaborates it all the Pioneers were on
board with this issue you have to be and
you know why they don't like it they
don't like it because if Jesus went into
the most holy then there is no Remnant
correct then you don't there's nothing
to stand out there's no 1844 it
disappears and the Remnant that is to
call the people out of Babylon becomes
part of the soup which is Babylon
especially the Christian soup correct
and then you can sit on economical
councils whose aim is to unite all
Christendom and think it being fine
because you're basing your theology on a
pile of potash so then you get rid of
the investigative judgment you get rid
of 1844 and as you just mentioned you
get rid of the remnant correct son I had
quite a nice discussion with this young
man and he wants to know should he study
further or should he be further deceived
by these people
said study further you know the truth
stand strong stand strong for the truth
Daniel went there yes Daniel was there
he was in the midst of Babylon and come
out firing on all cylinders and preach
the truth and let the theologians go to
the left and let them go to the right if
it's not from God they'll get nowhere
amen
why are we off on the tangent Martin
because this is a little thing that I
think also God can put there with he
hates this because this is this is
misleading it's it is deception okay so
God has been leading a people not as an
absentee law landlord but one very
present he even put the prophetic gift
into the remnant church he writes it in
the Bible that it would be there and
these people negate it as if it were
nothing it is most vexing to me
I have a righteous indignation
it is it Riles me up as well because it
shows you because you can see when these
how these things are taking people away
from the true word and the true meanings
so come back to the word come back to
the testimonies because that's what the
Bible said what you must do and none of
these things should perturb you no let
them Sail on their little sailboat to
nowhere and see where it gets them it'll
get them nowhere keep to your duty keep
to your duty
but let's continue and let let's not get
riled up let's get our revs down to a
nice calm level
so if we put the words I hate
into the search engine
that's let's say the search engine of
esode for example
and then we will find the phrase 16
times so what can we learn from these
verses it's important
because you know God is so misunderstood
for example if you take something like
uh I think it's in James where he says
God temps no one God cannot be tempted
and God tempts no one and then you find
all these verses like God tempted
Abraham God tempted David pardoned
pharaohs yeah hard and Pharaoh's heart
and all of these verses and then people
say the Bible contradicts itself it does
not contradict itself
if the definitive verse says God cannot
be tempted and God never tempts anyone
that's the Baseline that's it no
so any other Temptation that comes along
is what God's permits
and if God permits it in the Hebrew
mindset it is like God is actually doing
it but he's not doing it an agent is
doing it the devil and then if you doubt
that this is the case you go to job
again and you get the definition you get
the storyline of how it works exactly so
we have to we have to reason from cause
to effect you cannot take isolated
things and and throw the whole Bible
into a waste paper basket because of
that
so 16 times
we use the word I hate and yet God
forbids you to hate yeah so obviously
now there must be a dichotomy somewhere
right okay so what can we learn from
these verses the answer is obviously God
hates sin
but our problem is that we project the
hatred to the perpetrator
I hate him because he does this that or
the other we should never ever say that
we should say I hate what he does and
when you do something and somebody tells
you
this is wrong or that you're doing this
don't get riled up towards that person
because now you think he's you always do
you do it just accept listen and
change button
are you very cheered when your wife puts
you in your place
nope I don't think anybody has cheered
When anybody tells you listen what
you're doing now is not right
fortunately she hardly ever does it
like I said at the camp meeting every
minute of every day of every hour my
family started learning it's not that
bad it's time you started learning well
it's true but the point is if you're
honest and you sit down
and think about it
then you must admit that uh
sometimes they have a point oh yeah
mostly always
all right let's leave it at that
okay so what are these verses
First Kings 22 verse 8 and the king of
Israel said unto Jehoshaphat
there is yet one man Mikaya the son of
imla by whom we may inquire of the Lord
but I hate him
for he does not prophesy good concerning
me but evil
and Joseph had said let not the king say
so
it sounds familiar so he got rebuked
there
but this is basically what Humanity does
right
they project their hatred to the one
same with Ahab and Elijah you trouble of
Israel yeah
right and Jezebel hated him and said he
would she would destroy him well Jezebel
still hates the anti-typical Elijah and
wants to destroy him I mean all the
Flack that Wicked
is it too guided towards us because
who's saying saying this we we're saying
it but from where does it come well just
what we said in the beginning now about
what some of the theologians teach is
going to cause waves so you know if it
causes waves
then let it cause waves because it's the
truth and the problem is that it's
directed towards what we say but that
that we say is actually biblical yes so
you're not your anger is not is only
guided towards us because you're getting
angry of what where it comes from
correct correct
second chronicles 18 verse 7 and the
king of Israel said unto Jehoshaphat
there is yet One Man by whom we may
inquire of the Lord so it's the same
verse
but I hate him
for he never prophesied good unto
minimum if he never prophesied good unto
him why didn't the king sit down and
think about it
what is it that prevents Humanity from
sitting down and thinking about it
because you don't want to take
responsibility and you think that you
cannot be wrong
Rebellion is as the sin of witchcraft
and the spirit of Prophecy says I doubt
with a genuine Rebellion is ever curable
you know what you actually mentioned
that that uh camp meeting now you also
had a
uh of saying maybe you can explain it to
us that people will rather do the thing
than have to change the heart yes they
love a ritual
that's why the papacy in all its
documentation
places huge emphasis on liturgy
liturgy is everything that happens in a
church event other than the preaching of
the word of God
so it's the lighting the candles the
marching around the dancing the blowing
of the shofars the blowing of the
trumpets the hoo-ha and the haha and
every Pomp and glamor that is associated
with it
and I think I asked the question if you
take the coronation of bunny Prince
Charles into King Charles
there was a lot of Pomp and glamor and
coaches and gold and glitter and horses
that have been trained to walk in
particular ways and it's all very very
impressing and totally meaningless
meaningless
because it's going to lead to nothing
but people are over awed and had a
wonderful experience of emptiness that's
it and that's the same like you said so
now if you do all these rituals right
and everything and you can go and sit
back and say ah I did it I didn't have
to do anything I'm fine now I've been to
church I've listened to the trumpet I
was overwhelmed sank back into my chair
had a spiritual experience and I'm done
at least now I can get back to my booze
and my cigarettes and my barbecues and
and kick my shoes off and if the dog
irritates me give him a kick yeah that
sounds I don't have to change now that
makes me that whole episode makes me
think of what we're dealing with here
the whole question of I do not want to
change Christ came to set us free from
sin
but they have replaced ritual
with heart searching and that is the
problem that we have
so
is it ever curable is it ever curable
Martin there's a verse which should make
one shudder in the Bible
and that's Proverbs 28 verse 9.
he that turneth away his ear from
hearing the law
even his prayer shall be abomination
that is
what do you say about that Martin I
think if we really sit and listen and go
and think about this it is scary
how easy do we lower our standards or
compromise
and then by while compromising we leave
the law behind Okay now I think God has
compassion on those
who genuinely don't understand because
they've been deceived of course because
if you know it not
then God will wink at it
but if you know
that you are deliberately transgressing
God's law
or transgressing the Torah his word the
law
and even your prayers and Abomination
you know that brings up things like
Deliverance Ministry
uh we got a little bit of feedback
when you made a comment about
Deliverance Ministry
and people some people were a little bit
perturbed by the way in which we
addressed it
but the fact of the matter is Martin
some of the Deliverance Ministries that
you have look by the way let's get it
quite plain preaching the gospel is
Deliverance Ministry that's true right
yeah so we're not against Deliverance
Ministry it must be in the right context
it must be in the right context just
preaching the gospel ease Deliverance
Ministry
but if you go and somebody is possessed
and you go in there and you make a fiery
speech and command the devil to leave
and all of a sudden everything is peace
and quiet and you leave and you've had a
very successful Deliverance Ministry
that's a deception Martin because that
is almost going
linking on to exorcism
it's exactly the same thing because
if you turn your way from hearing the
law if you turn away your ear from
hearing the law even your prayer
is an Abomination you cannot go in and
do Deliverance Ministry without asking
some very pertinent questions what are
you doing in your life
is there something that is standing
between you and the protection of God
is there something that you are
permitting in your life whatever it is
it could be something you're watching on
television in secret you could have some
secret voice that you are practicing or
you are violent or you are drinking or
you are involved in illicit Affairs or
whatever whatever it is and something
large it can be something small anything
and if you don't address that
and the person isn't willing to change
there's no point in a Deliverance Prayer
you might as well just leave same for
the sick the same if somebody is bent on
destruction by following a lifestyle
which is contrary to health
there's no point even praying for that
person and it stands the spirit of
Prophecy acknowledges it correct
so these are all very important things I
can just also maybe add on to this if
you have any doubt on these Deliverance
things go and read Alberta Rivera has
got a huge thing about this because he
was a Jesuit priest he actually did
exorcisms I mean you you mentioned
you're in your um I think in the book as
well about the priest correct that came
to do the Deliverance Ministry for at
your house it was a total deception it
was a total fast but it looked so real
it looked so real and therefore you
think
your course is Justified because the
problem has been taken away
but you haven't corrected what was
standing in the way in the first place
it's a false it's a false
sense of hope that's a problem
all right so he that turneth away his
ear from hearing the law even his prayer
shall be an Abomination let that sink in
and think about it so God wants us to
correct
repent is always the first word that is
mentioned repent
turn turn from your evil ways for why
would you die o House of Israel
right how often I would have gathered
you like a mother hen but you would not
stubbornness true
Psalms 103 verse 1 I will set no Wicked
thing before mine eyes I hate the work
of them that turn aside it shall not
cleave to me mutton
doesn't that fit in with what we just
said
if you are
putting wicked things before thine eyes
and becoming desensitized to what we
call sin that little box
that little box the best thing that can
happen to that little box is to burn
every fuse that's in it
it's evil it is
because it propagates evil and makes
evil acceptable
every wicked and evil thing is portrayed
on that box get rid of it yeah
if you want to watch something watch
decent things that you download for
yourself that's it don't get a feed that
feeds the channeling to you yes how many
of our youth are watching the series
Lucifer oh
well even chosen even chosen for where
it says follow your heart the heart is
wicked
exceedingly Wicked above all the
detective above all things we have to be
so careful what we watch so that we
aren't led into a false sense of
security
Psalms 119 verse 104.
through thy precepts I get understanding
therefore I hate every false way
modern is there a parallelism there
of course there's the Hebrew parallelism
the precepts tell you what is right and
they give you understanding
and the false way must be contrary to
the precepts and the more you study the
precepts and you implement it the more
you hate the other one correct either
turneth away from his ear from the law
even his prayer shall be an Abomination
isn't it exactly the same thing just in
different words yeah
but people don't like it no
we never like it when we have to change
something for the better
those are the most brilliant laws ever
devised ten little laws
ten little laws and they address the
whole of humanity you take that away and
you have to have thousands of laws just
to replace one yes you can't remember
the first one when you start with the
last one
all right I hate vain thought
but thy law do I love is there again a
parallel yeah
is it a recurring theme it must be okay
so how's the thing that people say we
can do away with the law
because then again you feel better
because of all the things that you can
now do without any guilt like like we
said again this weekend there are only
four religions in the world
only for one of them is the truth and
three of them are the LIE
all right all those three have thousands
of sub-categories but they basically
fall into three categories
the first one is the dragon religion
we've dealt with this before Dragon
religion says did God really say say
questions the word of God from the very
first sentence in the beginning God
he questions it from there to the very
last verse in the Book of Revelation
okay so that's
Dragon religion
and then it says you will surely not die
the teaching of the immortality of the
souls Dragon religion
and you will be like God
so that incorporates every new age
philosophy that's out there in the world
every spiritualistic philosophy
and then you have a beast religion yeah
that's the second one that's the second
one the Beast religion says
uh you're saved by your works
you're not saved through faith
in the atoning blood of Jesus Christ so
let's get rid of Jesus Christ as the
only savior of the world that's Beast
religion that's what Catholicism teaches
Jesus never died for you
does Islam believe the same thing yes
therefore it's a beast religion
does Judaism believe the same thing yes
it's the best religion that's why they
could make the abrahamic faith family
house correct with those three the
Catholic church at the head yes so let's
have a beautiful Triune church but let's
leave Jesus outside the door nobody
comes to the father except by me it's a
false religion that's a beast religion
by the way
does the Beast Catholicism believe in
the immortality of the Soul
yes yes of course they believe in the
immortality of the Soul doesn't their
catechism say that Jesus died so that we
may become Gods so isn't that Dragon
religion so are they married to the
dragon yes the dragon is their father
that's the one they pray to
because they cannot pray to the father
really because they have to go through
Jesus and they just threw him out the
back door so obviously they're praying
to the devil right am I being very harsh
no you I'm just quoting the Bible right
either turneth away his ear from the law
so all the best religions
negate Jesus
all the Beast religions rely on their
Works to get to heaven no matter what
category you want to call them no matter
what whether you want to call it
Buddhism whether you want to call it
whether you want to call it
whatever you like it's exactly the same
thing it's a beast religion yeah and
then you have the false prophet is the
saddest of them all yes that's the most
dangerous at this stage all right does
he accept Jesus yes but which one all
right but nevertheless he accepts Jesus
right that's it he's protestantism does
he have dragon religion does he believe
in the immortality of the Soul yes yes
so he swallowed a bit of dragon religion
there
uh is he willing for the sake of
compromise to sit with the Beast yes
and pretend that he's worshiping the
same Jesus that's the thing isn't that a
false prophet yes isn't he lying to you
isn't he saying that that Jesus is the
same as our Jesus the one that has to
sit outside never died for you and never
saved you it's compromising so the worst
of them all is the false prophet it is
that's some deception the most deceptive
and he makes Fire come down from heaven
yeah and he jumps around and says he's
received the Holy Spirit commands Devils
to come up while negating the law yes
Miracles upon miracles in a nutshell
Martin I'm sorry to have to say that but
that's the way it is and we'll probably
get a blast for this but uh that's the
way it is read your Bibles that's it all
right
so we come to the same thing over and
over again therefore I esteem all thy
precepts concerning all things to be
right and I hate every false way
it's a aren't the two always in
juxtaposition the law the precepts and
the hate the whole time so just to make
it clear again we if like you've just
mentioned these religions we don't hate
the people in them no we hate what they
are standing for we must evangelize them
come out of this terrible system
you cannot be part of it don't
go and join them just get them out just
because someone blows the shafar 50
times in a service doesn't make it right
no
all right let's look at Psalms 119 verse
I hate and abhor lying
but thy Lord do I love do we again have
a juxtaposition is there a law which
says Thou shalt not lie exactly thou
shalta bring false testimony
all right now if the false prophet says
that these people that are sitting there
in the Beast are our brothers and
sisters while they negate Jesus aren't
they lying to them to their members
they're lying oh
can you bring people to Jesus with a
false falsehood all right I always come
back to the coronation of Bonnie Prince
Charlie where he sits with a reed in the
one hand and the cantaloupe in the other
hand
and now it's being coronated right
and he represents the crown
now of course people don't know that the
crown owns everything owns all land you
own nothing everything belongs to the
crown everything belongs to the crown
but the crown has been seated to the
Vatican yeah
people must look at those old lectures
the beamable sustainable princes and all
of those and see what really is going on
the Pope in Rome is the one who is in
command and I just saw an article that
the the greatest shareholder in the
entire world is the Vatican is the pope
and that article is from 1965. yes okay
imagine how big it is now correct
perhaps you should show that I'll put
that I'll put that article on put that
article on just and I'll blast it in
here I'll link it in the description
again yes so Martin this is a terrible
terrible deception
and it's based on lies lies nothing but
lies
hate lies all lies yes and they call
truth hate speech
that's true hey yeah they have the goal
to call truth hate speed from where they
are lying from morning till night but
according to the scripture that's the
fact of that whether you like it or not
Psalms 139 verse 21 is a complicated one
do not I hate them oh Lord that hate
thee
and am not I grieved with those that
rise up against thee
now those are the words of David
I hate them O Lord
that hate thee let's put a little rebuke
there in for David and say do not I hate
what they do that hate thee that would
have been perhaps a better way of
putting it
but that's how you should read it that's
how you should read it because I'm sure
that is what he meant because by
definition
we're not supposed to even hate our
brother or our neighbor right
you must love your neighbor
so you can't hate your neighbor and love
your neighbor at the same time so we
must learn to separate the deed
from the person that's it That's
essential
and that's something that the Holy
Spirit must do
right because if you do it on your own
you're going to mess it up so it's
better that the absentee loan landlord
leaves that to the Holy Spirit otherwise
it might not be genuine it's a
okay
he goes on to gets even worse I hate
them with a perfect hatred I count them
mine enemies
well Martin
I also count these people that teach
false Doctrine like that Jesus went into
the most holy at the Ascension I also
hate what they teach
me because it's false yeah it's based on
a lie
and it's based on ecumenism and there's
an evil agenda behind it and not a
genuine search for truth
Proverbs 8 13 the fear of the Lord is to
hate evil there we have it in a nutshell
beautifully put the fear of the Lord is
to hate evil
so what is evil Pride
arrogancy and the evil way and the
forward mouth
do I hate
so it's not the person no that's what
he's doing what does this tell us isn't
this talking about character correction
character correct side
and in order to to bring this across
we should have empathy for people that
are erring
but I have very little empathy for
people who are deliberately rebellious
what does Paul say we should do to them
hand them over to Satan let them be
buffeted let them be buffeted that they
may learn a better way I don't want
anyone to be lost no
if I could go so far I wouldn't want the
devil to be lost but he is lost because
he's made his choice and he's sinned
against the Holy Spirit and God feels
the same way
but I wouldn't want anyone to be lost
not even my worst enemy
but that's what they should turn turn
turn from their evil ways
and stop deceiving God's people because
that's what really making me sad
is how you can see it is taking people
away from God
the teachings that these people do
correct Isaiah 61 verse 8 for I the Lord
love judgment
I hate robbery for burnt offering
thing one how would you put that in a
modern context I hate robbery for burnt
offering in other words if you are
robbing God
by pretending that your works are good
enough
God hates it
so the whole Beast system is appalling
because you think that if you do a
pilgrimage
or you're partaking a mass or you pray
to a dead Saint who knows nothing or you
go into a seance type meeting with a
dead Saint and then you portray it on
television as virtuous
then you have a major major problem on
your hands because God forbids you to go
to the witch of Endor or to the god of
ekron
so Martin if this is robbery false
offerings in other words
works
as an attempt to appease God
and I will direct their Works in truth
and I will make an Everlasting Covenant
with them
and again you come back to truth Jesus
is the truth the word is the truth the
law is the truth you can't get away from
it it's everywhere
Jeremiah 44 4. how be it I sent unto you
all my servants the prophets
Rising early and sending them send
saying oh do not this abominable thing
that I hate
does that apply to the remnant yes very
much it does very much so did he send a
prophet to the remnant
to take the place of the Bible right no
no to be the lens that's it or to be the
telescope that's it to have a look at
what this word has to say like we've
mentioned before
Satan is blowing smoke in front of your
eyes
we got a prophet to help clear a little
bit of that and see clearly again are
there personal rebukes in those writings
oh yes
and they're only for those people right
or do they portray principles that's it
and that's the important thing because
you take it personally do they apply to
you no to every single person you know
when my wife started reading testimonies
I was amazed at how she read it
yeah
she read it to find out what was wrong
in her and to correct it and she
couldn't wait to see what to correct
and other people read it and they feel
affronted and angry that's it that's the
two Spirits it depends on your motive
Lord what is wrong with me I know that I
I was born with a bent character
and the the circumstances of my
upbringing went exactly Rosy so what can
you expect a beautiful straight spear no
a crooked one right it has to be
straightened out
and God uses many many ways he talks to
you through his spirit
and through your wife
and through your children children and
through your acquaintances and your
parents for young people exactly
and we need to have that introspection
you see but the thing is I I think if we
lack that that your wife had if you lack
the Lord show me what else is wrong and
you read through the spirit of Prophecy
and you see oh but this is a hard one
because it
is this really so bad
let us God to help you yes to overcome
this and really want to and the
interesting thing is Martin those things
that don't seem so bad
are really the worst one exactly because
that small one but that's that our scene
okay so he sent the prophets
and he wanted to show them what he hates
and if you want to please God then you
will listen
I hate says Amos 5 21.
I despise your feast days
did God not Institute he did so what's
he saying here oh no he doesn't know
what he's saying of course he knows what
he's saying what they did is they took
the essence out and turned it into a
liturgy they're like the Pope
you take the essence out turn it into a
liturgy jump up and down bow 50 000
times use a lot of smoke and incense
and then you're holy yeah that's a heck
of a lot easier than changing your
character that's it don't so
all there's doing and not changing is
not getting you anywhere all right
and I will not smell in your solemn
assemblies you know previously he said
the sweet smelling Aroma unto the Lord
if the heart was right then that would
have been a sweet Aroma but now it's a
smelly assembly
or Zechariah 8 17 let none of you
imagine evil in your hearts against his
neighbor and love no false oath for all
these things that I hate says the Lord
we mustn't lie we mustn't swear at your
yes be yes and your no be no
Romans for that which I do I allow not
for what I would that do I not but what
I hate that I do
or that do I
is talking about human nature he's
talking about our rebellious spirit
and it needs to go to the blacksmith
yeah
and he needs to put that into the fire
and then use the Anvil and the hammer
which means it's not easy and it's
probably not without some pain
with a lot of framework
a lot of fun we all need a whack and we
we continually need it and when we think
we're great and we need a super whack
yeah all right
okay
so for that which I do I allow not
for what I would that do I not but what
I hate that I do and then he screams out
in desperation who will save me from
this body of death and then he has a
solution thanks be to God Amen there is
a solution
Revelation 2 verse 15 so has there also
them that hold to the doctrine of the
nicolations which thing I hate
the nicolaations
they were against the law of God it
comes back to the same thing over and
over again the the war is against Christ
and his law that's it
in other words the law the wise against
Christ's character yeah
and the Jews could only handle his
character three and a half years then
they had to crucify him get rid
that's how long Humanity actually could
keep up with him but after the
crucifixion and some of them thought
about it three thousand were added in
one day so it's possible to change but
if you take it for the since then for
the last two thousand years
the character of Christ has caused many
to be killed yes because once again the
majority hates that character well you
see the devil knows that he can play his
tune
on the distorted character of humanity
because it harmonizes with him yeah it's
so easy and he'll sing this beautiful
tune to them
and they all run along like the Pied
Piper rats and run off them to petition
no we have to turn away and we have to
make a
decision
so Martin what we're saying is we have
to separate Sin from sinners
and how important is it that we do that
if Jesus hadn't separated Sin from
Sinners would he would have would he
have come and died for us no no he
wouldn't have had any reason no would he
have sat with publicans and prostitutes
no he would have only went to sit in the
kingly court yes or the temple with the
Sanhedrin exactly so you have to
separate the sin from The Sinner
let's say someone abducts your children
or someone steals your husbands or
wife's affections
what do you hate
the sin or The Sinner
these things happen to just about
everybody who lives in this world right
at some stage or other
somewhere in your life something
terrible happened
not everybody gets their children
abducted but I can assure you that's one
of the most painful experiences that you
can experience
so what is worse someone steals your
goods
or someone steals your affections or
steals affections what's worse well I
think affections well it depends on how
attached you were to your goods all
right someone steals your car
and you're angry or someone comes and
steals your wife what's gonna rile you
up more no definitely the second part
the second one will value up more right
how does God feel
someone stole all his children that's
the thing
so every single one
and no matter how much love he pours out
they cling to the abductor
and it happens like this as well in the
world today and there's a thing called
Stockholm syndrome where people honor
and love and adore their torturer we
spoke last time about people love
dictators yes it's the same
it's a syndrome yes
so Martin think about that someone
abducts your children who someone steals
your husband or wife's affection or what
do you hate that's another sinner if you
go and you see if if I think about
movies
vengeful movies you always are on the
side of the guy who takes Revenge if
something like this happens yes because
you feel that's righteous indignation no
it's absolutely wrong if Jesus had done
that to us we would have all been
obliterated
all right
how important is it that we learn
repentance
it's most important because without
repentance you fall into all these
categories and you cannot see God you
cannot come to God without repentance
it's absolutely essential that you
repent now what's all of this got to do
with an absentee landlord
tell us
Martin if you were present 24 7 around
us
to keep telling us would he be able to
speak to the heart or would we just look
no we'll sit there constantly in death
listen so we have to learn it now
through his representative
because in his wisdom he knows that's
the only way it's going to work and we
can do it then now that by the time he
comes to fetch us this will be sorted
out yes it must be sorted out must be
sorted out forever because the Bible
said sin will not raise its head a
second time and he's not going to change
your character when he comes no it's
going to change now
button
we have a lot of things to talk about
end times and what's happening in the
world and that's all very interesting
and very important but this is more
important exactly and I think that's why
the Lord has led our discussions in this
way
for the past four weeks five weeks
this is more on our mind and the Lord is
showing to discuss this time is short
time is short we have to we have to we
have to
let the Lord change us
Luke 5 32 says I came not to call the
righteous
but send us to repentance
and you know Deliverance without
repentance means nothing's empty
15 verse 7 I say unto you that likewise
Joy shall be in heaven over one sinner
that repenteth more than over 99 just
persons who need no repentance
what is the Lord looking for
change of heart okay now if somebody if
you're looking for someone to bleed to
the Lord than to lead to repentance are
you looking for a righteous person or
are you looking for a sinner sinner the
one that's hurting and lost and he
doesn't probably even know it it doesn't
even know why it's lost now he doesn't
know why he's sinning he doesn't even
know what sin is
okay I'm okay I've never killed anyone
is that really a Criterion you've killed
thousands just by hating them yeah
and that repentance Luke 24 47 and
remission of sins should be preached in
his name amongst all nations beginning
at Jerusalem
so every single person on the entire
Earth must learn about repentance
because without repentance there's no
remission of sins
and what is sin the transgression of the
law
Matthew 26 28 for this is my blood of
the new testament which is shed for many
for the remission of sins
it's a recurring theme
and we don't get it
and it's so subtly portrayed that you do
not need repentance just follow your
heart yeah
just follow your heart believe in
yourself believe in yourself
Hebrews 9 22 and almost all things are
by the law perched with blood and
without shedding of blood is no
remission there goes the entire Beast
system of religion in the world whatever
category it is whatever name it has it
is irrelevant
if you do not believe
that the blood of Christ purged you from
your sins you are a beast religion
finished and so it's important once
again I'm gonna I just want to mention
it again
yes those people can be loving in
everything but you cannot leave them
there no you have to get them out they
cannot be saved in that and they might
be willfully deceived or unwillfully
deceived it doesn't matter they're
deceived and it's our so they see that
Commission to make disciples or even to
preach to people
is that meant for The Sinner and the
lost or is it only to go and tell them
Jesus loves them and leave them there
you know why it's so unpopular because
as soon as you preach that you are saved
by the blood of the Lamb
your works are negated they're
meaningless
and people don't like that
then one they want to be righteous
just to think about it on what do we
measure if a person is good
it's 90 out on his way on his Works yes
his works
and it can be as evil as he's like as
long as he's a philanthropist and gives
a few million dollars to an orphanage oh
that's wonderful
and that must cover a multitude of sins
which now come out in the news media and
we see where all this led to and how it
developed let's not go there
Hebrews 10 verse 18 now where remission
of these is there's no more offering for
sin
very important you have to have
remission
before you can be cleansed so that you
can stand before God that's basically
what it says to be able to stand when
Jesus comes correct so let's go to
testimonies for the church volume Five
and read what it says about without
repentance there can be no forgiveness
there's a great need today of just such
sincere heartfelt repentance and
confession
those who have not humbled their souls
before God in acknowledging their guilt
have not yet fulfilled the first
condition of acceptance
you see the harmony between the Bible
and the spirit of Prophecy no wonder
they hate though
if we have not experienced that
repentance which is not to be repented
of
and have not confessed our sins with
true humiliation of soul and Brokenness
of spirit
abhorring our iniquity
we have never saw truly for the
forgiveness of sin
if we if you go back
and we go to the previous slides and you
read again through those Biblical verses
and you read this again this is just
putting that
in more
in that more understandable way almost
if you want to put it absolutely correct
absolutely Martin I'm tempted
I'm tempted
I know we've discussed this a thousand
times we're going to Matthew chapter
five
verse 3.
blessed are the poor in spirit for
theirs is the kingdom of heaven
and the poverty that it speaks about
there is abject poverty
worse than the Widow with the final
might
nothing you have nothing to offer in
other words if you realize that you are
bankrupt
absolutely destitute
that's the first step towards being
blessed
if you think that you are rich and
increasing Goods
you don't qualify for the first step on
the ladder you have to be empty so that
you can be filled all right so blessed
are the poor in spirit you realize your
bankruptness
and blessed are they that mourn
for they shall be comforted
for what
mourn for your sinful condition
if you realize
that that you are a sinner
that you are bankrupt
and that you are hopelessly hopelessly
lost
that's the second condition and you have
to feel a sorrow for what you have done
and what you were and what you are
the same kind of Sorrow that a mother
would have for the loss of an only child
that's the second one
and then you have to get off your high
horse
blessed are the meek for thy shall
inherit the earth
the world takes these Beatitudes and
distorts them to such an extent that
they do not reflect the Plan of
Salvation at all but glorify man
and the peacemakers suddenly become the
politicians
that sit with Epstein on their Island in
between acts doesn't make any sense
whatsoever so the first condition is
your bankruptcy your second condition is
you must feel sorrow for your sins your
third condition is you must come down
from your high horse and realize that
you are in need of help
and then you must blessed are they which
hunger and thirst of the righteousness
for they shall be filled you must ask
Lord lead me in the right way I want to
do what is right show me what is wrong
show me what to do help me help me I
can't do it by myself and that like you
said earlier for how your wife reads it
help me to want to change yes so you
must hunger and thirst after this
righteousness you must realize that the
way you were is not the way you can stay
and then once you've come to that point
then you can be merciful to others
blessed are the merciful for they shall
obtain Mercy why will you be merciful
because you obtained Mercy
and then you can have compassion on the
other person this is a progression this
is a ladder where you climb and you you
progress in your Christian experience
and then you wrestle with it evil in
your mind and the sewerage draining
system that is
occupied your brain since birth
and you say Lord I I cannot stand it
anymore I I want to have pure thoughts I
don't wanna I don't even want to think
about these things anymore
you know one of the reasons why we will
be getting a new language
in heaven
is because all the evil words that are
in our present language must go that's
it and even if it's a good word there is
in some way evil connotation to
something and tested it and doubled up
and made it evil and vile so we'll have
to get a new language for those of you
who think that German is going to be the
language of Heaven I've got news for you
it's not going to be the language and
neither is English Afrikaans also
Afrikaans definitely also not because
that's got some of the most powerful
words under the sun
the best language to be angry in is
Afrikaans
that's true that's true it's Gotta Go
so we have to ask the Lord Lord give us
this pureness of heart
and once you've got that Martin
then you can be a peacemaker then only
then you cannot start off as a
peacemaker with all this high horse
things though and then you must know
what peace is all about great peace at
those who love thy law
so if you do not attach the Lord to your
peacemaking you are practicing it in
vain
are they attaching the law of God to
their peacemaking no no exactly the
opposite they're negating it United
Nations is for peace but there's no law
oh god there it's steeped in occultism
based on Alice a Bailey and blavatsky
theology which glorifies Lucifer is
there any peace or law in that none
and blessed are they which are
persecuted for righteousness sake so
Martin once you start reflecting this
character
you'll get the same treatment as Jesus
got they'll hate you I'll hate you not
because you're evil but because you
display their evil through your attitude
you your
accuser of them without you actually
saying a word correct
and then blessed are ye when men shall
revile you and persecute you and shall
say all manner of evil against you
falsely for my sake once you've
progressed through this line they're
going to do it you're goody goody two
shoes they even do it in school yeah you
know teacher's pet you're the granny
yeah right you can't do right without
being reviled and if you start standing
like on the truth of God you're also
going to get all right now you can get
better or better when this starts
happening
but the last one is so wonderful
rejoice and be exceeding glad for great
is your reward in heaven for so
persecuted they the prophets which were
before you isn't that beautiful there's
a promise that's the progression that we
have to go through so repentance is the
very first one sorrow for sin
sorrow for your condition
and if we have never sought we have
never found the peace of God
you have to seek for it
the only reason why we may not have
remission of sins that are passed is
that we are not willing to Humble our
proud hearts and comply with the
conditions of the word of Truth didn't
we just read that
you must become meek
that's it you must climb off that high
horse
this explicit instruction given
concerning this matter
confession of sin
whether public or private should be
heartfelt and freely expressed it is not
to be urged from The Sinner it is not to
be made in a flippant and careless way
or forced from those who have no
realizing sense of the abhorrent
character of sin
the confession that is mingled with
tears and sorrow
that is the outpouring of the inmost
Soul Finds Its way to the god of
infinite pity
says the psalmist the Lord is nigh unto
them that are of a broken heart and save
as such as be of a contrite spirit
the trouble is you meet so many people
that don't understand
the nature of sin
and therefore why should they repent if
they have nothing to repent of you have
the saying or would be only human
yes
no that's not supposed to be our
attitude
we should say oh we're human so we need
God more we need God more
so the same danger exists today amongst
the people who profess to be the
depositories of God's law
they are too apt to flatter themselves
that the Regard in which they hold the
Commandments
will preserve them from the power of
divine Justice
they refuse to be reproved for evil and
charge God's servants with being too
zealous in putting sin out of the camp
a sin hating God calls upon those who
profess to keep his law to depart from
all iniquity
you can't say well I've discovered the
truth now I can Revel in it
it's got to change you
neglect to repent and obey's word will
bring as serious consequences upon God's
people today
as did the same sin upon ancient Israel
there's a limit Beyond which you will no
longer delay his judgments
I have such an urgency
I can see the judgments of God coming
and if God's people are not ready
they will not be partakers in the loud
cry we will walk the same way Asia
ancient Israel and if they're not part
of the loud cry
then they're part of the crowd yeah
there's another one help in daily living
we are never alone
whether we choose him or not we have a
companion
remember that wherever you are
whatever you do God is there he's not an
absentee landlord Martin no
nothing that is said or done or thought
can escape his attention
to your every word or deed you have a
witness the holy sin-hating God
powerful
and we read it that we'd not read in
these Bible verses how he hates sin yes
so is the spirit of Prophecy in harmony
is it taking the place of the Bible no
is it putting a telescope on it it's
coloring it in
before you speak or act always think of
this as a Christian you are a member of
the Royal Family
a child of the Heavenly King say no word
do no act that shall bring dishonor upon
the worthy name
by which you are called
Christian right yeah
Christian
so modern day we say the landlord has
gone on a long journey and left his
representatives to present his case yes
yes we can say that yeah you're an
ambassador okay
does this test the sincerity of the
representatives no definitely is
wouldn't it test more than if it were
present
because you could leave it all up to him
then you can just say listen to him yeah
there you go I don't have to change
Deuteronomy 4 29.
but if from thence Thou shalt seek the
Lord thy God Thou shalt find them
if they are seek him with all thy heart
and with all thy soul
seeking
is the first prerequisite
I I remember that day so
distinctly when I sat in that Catholic
Church all alone
and couldn't understand why I couldn't
speak to God because he was locked up in
that box
with a little red light
and I said if you exist show yourself to
me that's seeking right that's it I
never expected such a powerful answer
now you're sitting here now I'm sitting
here yeah
Matthew 7 verse 7 ask and it shall be
given given you seek and you shall find
knock and it shall be opened unto you if
you don't seek it shows you don't have a
need
you think you've you're increasing Goods
you're okay yeah you're okay Jack
acts 17 27 that they should seek the
Lord if happily they might feel of them
and find them they'll be not far from
every one of us is there an absentee
landlord no no not at all no so let's
have a look at some of the Parables of
Jesus in this regard
the parable of the tenants
hear another Parable Matthew 21 from
verse 33 there was a certain householder
which planted a Vineyard that's his
church right
and hedged it round about but how did he
do that by putting the law around it
that's it
and dig the wine press in it
so that they can spread the gospel the
message the wine the doctrine
and build a tower
in other words make it visible prominent
people must know about it it's not
somewhere hidden under a bushel
and let it out to the husbandmen and
then he went into a far country it
became an absentee landlord but he left
everything's there what is it
everything's there
and when the time of the fruit Drew near
that's the Harvest Mountain
that's now
he sent his servants to the husbandmen
that they might receive the fruits of it
but they were busy with the Beast and
the false prophet yeah negotiating a
peace treaty without Christ
and the husbandman took his servants
and beat one
and killed another
and stoned another
talking about the prophets
again he sent other servants more than
the first than they did unto them
likewise
but last of all he sent unto them his
son saying they will reverence my son
but when the husband men saw the son
they said amongst themselves this is the
air come let us kill him and let us
seize on his inheritance
they want the inheritance but they don't
want the character exactly they want to
do the thing but don't have want to
change the heart
isn't that exactly what happened
must be one of the saddest parables in
the Bible
it is
and they caught him and cast him out of
the vineyard and slew him
and when the Lord thereof of the
vineyard cometh what will he do unto
those husbandmen
they sent Amy will miserably destroy
those wicked men and will let out his
Vineyard unto other husbandmen so away
he took it from Israel they
pronounce their own sentence upon
themselves they asked them what would
they do and he gave it to the Gentiles
and we've now reached the point where
the Gentiles are doing exactly the same
thing as Israel did
sacrificing Christ for the sake of peace
and an Earthly pathetic Kingdom
based on
poor sewage systems
that's it
what travesty
Jesus said unto them did you never read
in the scripture
the stone which the builders rejected
the same has become the head of the
corner
this is the Lord's doing and it is
marvelous in our eyes Martin
the stone that the builders rejected
the abrahamic house
is the stone there
no
no we're going to be talking about this
in the next one
I think it's time that we just bring
that up again the Stone's not there
because
that stone is missing but who's all
trying to give this peace and safety and
all this
those three religions
and the Stone's gone
it's not in any of them
pardon doesn't this
I almost said when to make you pull your
hair out and I think I will refrain from
there
foreign
Mark 13 32 but of that day in that hour
there was no man no not the Angels which
are in heaven neither the son but the
father
taking heed watch and pray for ye know
not when the time eased for the son of
man is as a man taking a far Journey
who left his house
and gave authority to his servants and
to every man his work and commanded the
porter to watch
we're back to square one
we're back to the same situation and
because he's now absent as an absentee
landlord
he can test the metal and the character
of those that he put in charge that's
purifying to see if they are true and
only those that are true will go through
to the kingdom the other will have to
sit with the Beast and the false prophet
and they will be in the lack of fire and
may we all study and want to be willing
to not be part of that that we can be
doesn't the Bible say where the Beast
and the false prophet are yeah in the
lack of fire do you want to be there no
so we have to
start studying and work
against this
watch is there for for you know not when
the Master of the House cometh at even
or at midnight or at the growing or
in the morning
this coming suddenly you find you
sleeping and what I say unto you I shall
say unto all watch
aren't we supposed to be a Watchmen on
the walls of Zion
when you see these things happening when
you see in front of your eyes
these abrahamic Accords this massive
economical push and you see the stone
lying over there
isn't that alarming for sure
if you see the
church and state starting to come
together
do you want to still be on the political
side no
so how do the representatives fare if
selfishness Creeps in
and we have a warning against
adulteresses
Proverbs 7 verse 1 my son keep my words
and lay up my Commandments with thee
that's the Hedge right
keep my Commandments and live that's the
Hedge
and my law is the apple of thine eye the
theme is recurring and nobody wants to
listen
bind them upon thy fingers write them
upon the table of thine heart
say unto wisdom Thou Art my sister and
call understanding thy King's woman
that they may keep thee from the strange
woman
from The Stranger with flatereth with
her words that's the false Church yeah
it's the abrahamic record
it is a strange woman it's a communism
because the Stone's lying over there
it cannot be built on the right
foundation
the Stone's gone
so don't listen to this strange woman
for at the window of my house I look
through my casement
and I beheld among the simple ones
I discerned among the youth the young
man void of understanding little
children
yes
the little children that
are supposed to believe what God Said
and there is someone
wandering past her and saying she looks
very nice what's wrong with her
passing through the street near her
corner what's it doing there
what's he doing near a corner should be
staying far away from her corner
and he went the way to her house that's
it he's done he's cooked
he's cooked Martin
someone when it says passing through the
street near a corner and he went the way
to a house Martin Martin
I I Shadow when I think of our people
going towards the house and saying oh
well we're just representing making
friends making friends what are you
doing there
in the Twilight in the evening in the
black and the dark night all of these
things happen behind closed doors
and behold there met him a woman with
the attire of a harlot and subtle of
heart
she's loud
and stubborn
her feet are bite not in our house
I shudder I shudder for God's people we
cannot pay homage to any of these three
religions that you were talking about
stay away from that now is she without
now in the streets lieth in weight at
every corner she's in the economical
world
she's in the political world she's in
the religious World she's in the occult
World she's everywhere Martin her little
tendrils
there they sit in the Lotus position the
Jesuits pretending to be
Hindus when they are Jesuits
they're pretending to be anything as
long as they can lure the young man to
come and have a look
like one person said
I read they left the Christian religion
because they love the cooking style of
the Buddhists well cooked like them why
do you have to leave the Cornerstone
I have peace offerings with me this day
I paid my vows
so she has a religious connotation
there came I forced to meet thee
diligently to seek thy face and I have
found thee so welcome in my economical
Council I have decked my bed with
coverings of tapestry with carved works
with fine linen of Egypt but I've
unfortunately discarded the
righteousness of Christ and the white
Robes of righteousness my linen is from
Egypt
hmm didn't they want to go down to Egypt
all the time all the time didn't they
seek with them's leaders to take them
back to Egypt
I have perfumed my bed with Mir and
aloes and cinnamon come and join me in a
mess
come let us take our full of love until
the morning let us Solace ourselves with
love for the Goodman is not at home
is an absentee landlord let me take care
of you
is gone on a long journey Martin
what a terrible trap right and the Bible
is so direct and so
clear to tell you these things and still
there we go there we go
it's taken a bag of money with him
and will come home at the day appointed
but don't worry I have lots of it I have
invested in every economic Enterprise on
the earth I have vaccines I have
everything to make you happy and to give
you money and to make you my slave I
have everything don't money how much do
you want you want to be a rock star I'll
throw Millions out did you want to be a
star follow your heart do what thou Wilt
is the whole of the law believe in
yourself forget about his money bags his
reward only comes one day my reward is
right here right now
am I exaggerating nope
surely you're not on this wavelength
modern
and yours yes oh definitely I am oh okay
because if you say it I can what about
talents
is it the talent if something that you
do takes you away from Christ exactly
so he's taken the money back with him
because he says his reward is with him
when he comes I'll give you the reward
right now okay
and we'll come home at the day appointed
that's way too long to wait come come
come to me
with her much fair speech she caused him
to yield with the flattering of her lips
she forced him
he goeth after her straight away as an
ox goes to the slaughter as a fool to
the correction of the stocks
terrible situation
we are living the reality thereof
for the Goodman is not at home
he's gone on a long journey let me take
care of it and that one is as well it's
a long journey it's not just a journey
strike through his liver as a bird
hastes through the snare knoweth not
that it is for his life
how can unto me now therefore owe you
children and attend to the words of my
mouth let not thine heart decline to her
ways go not astray in her path for she
has cast down many wounded
how many millions of people died in the
Middle Ages because of her yeah and all
the countless millions that we do not
know of through her communist regimes
and this and that and the other
terrible terrible history and how many
more will
through all the sorceries correct and
she's very busy with sorcery pharmacia
it's one of her favorite topics
so let not thine heart declined her away
go not to stray on her paths for she has
cast down many wounded yea many strong
men
have been slain by her
a house is the way to hell
going down to the chambers of death
serious warning Martin
serious warning and she here claims that
he is the absentee landlord therefore
she will take command and control and
she has
correct and she has
and with that Martin with that dire
warning we shall conclude our absentee
landlord statement
and ask the Lord to give us wisdom
to stay within the Hedge that he has
provided
not to go wandering up to her house
to see what they're up to
and then negotiate to join up with her
while the absentee landlord is gone
and she has the money bags to keep you
happy this makes me think of when the
mouse the cats away the mouse can play
yes this is about the same thing that
it's exactly the same thing so let's
pray
Heavenly Father
a very sad story
about the absentee landlord who is Not
absent at all
but who is testing hearts and Minds
help us to be on the right side of this
equation help us to be on the right side
of the law
help us to realize our need that we do
not become self-righteous because we
recognize the law
and help us Lord to realize that fine
linen from Egypt who will not suffice
only the Spotless robe of righteousness
by faith will do in this case
and help us not to reject it in Jesus
name amen
[Music]